all right bobby's safe let's stay with
bobby oh great i was gonna do asteroids
just chilling with homies
[Music]
i don't know any one of them their play
styles either so or even personalities
everything i feel like i'm good at
knowing if someone's lying some people
are just genuinely really good but some
people do give away little hints but i
think everyone in this lobby probably
played it
it's my first time playing this game
wait first time ever ever
why yeah so i'm like i swear to god so
i'm like nervous are you
already lying to us that sounds like a
lie that sounds pretty sucks
all right i'm here with charlie and that
no problem
oh that was fast you guys couldn't wait
a second huh jesus
it's right in front of electrical so
someone sliced them before they came in
i have a question for you
i can tell you what i saw because uh xqc
went yeah
and i think pink was uh with him as well
pink bobby you got something to say
yo i literally was outside right now
just going to
do some work i don't know i don't even
know this game this is my first time i
was literally doing work what oh
that sounds like a lot that's my first
game too man did you
have a question for you did you hit the
kill button yeah i did not
okay did you click them with a certain
answer hold on i have a quick question
so
me and dakotas did lights lights get
fixed i come out and you're just sitting
there on download how did you not see
the body of your report
i moved before there was a body yeah i
didn't go to lights i did my download i
stood at downloads
yeah but what was your pathing before
that sorry bobby
from the drop ship to downloads that's
all i did
it wasn't me i swear well you're the
last one i saw with xqc
wait so you didn't go
[Music]
i'm sorry what wait
it was pink right i can't remember
[Music]
all right we can take care of that test
later my goal is to not
die all right i wanna end up like xqc
there and just die right away because
that [ __ ] sucks
i don't play the game to win i play the
game to not die
and let me do the [ __ ] meteor i hate
this one yes yes
don't kill me the vision is so low
i've got some big info here so i can
clear lyric i had to wait for him on
scan lyrics good i have a question
for you somebody just ran by what's your
question charlie
so when you and i went to med bay we
held hands near the med bay thing i was
about to scan
and then you ran away and i completely
lost you
did anyone see i did the reactor didn't
you hear the bee
me and summit did it i did right side
some of the left i think that's actually
fair
okay did anyone here can anyone confirm
well now i'm walking back into med bay
um
i left past the protest the coach didn't
come at a drill when i left
see he said yes charlie what were you
doing then because you what what the
same way as eddie
yeah all right when she didn't i wanted
her to see medbay so she could see that
i was scanning but then she ran away and
then i
couldn't hear you i have a question like
what are you trying to be curious about
with each other no one i'm curious of
you something
i didn't see you do card swipe or flip
you just went right away and then you
went to node with adapt
yeah and he never came to do the flip
switch hey guys remember when it was
obviously bobby
you remember that wait during the
weekend
over here man yeah i'll be honest i mean
watching bobby play i feel like i feel
like he's just on another monitor he's
all tabbed
man [ __ ] i'm not gonna be able to be
this like alert
when i'm the imposter we'll see
uh oh uh oh do not come near me
who locked me yeah and then i'll finish
off with the specimen
hopefully no one vents and didn't get no
i'm dead
why did the doors lock there i'm so dead
[ __ ]
how do i survive this if i don't die now
it's even more confirmed
i'm staying oh look at that i'm running
i said that all right so the lights went
out right
yeah yeah yes train i think you're the
one that turned them off
right yes i fixed them yeah i did why do
you run to the lights
when the lights turn back
when the lights happen it's scary oh my
god you ran towards them when the lights
had turned back on that's hella
to me like adept was trying to kill no
yeah thank you
it did right
them okay okay now i feel bad it was
summit
summit i'm voting feud was in weapons i
walked up to the door i saw him
i walked back i knew some of it was
there i knew i was gonna be in kill
range if i stayed in weapons so i ran to
lights to try and be safe yeah but the
lights turned back on and you still ran
towards them that's why i saw
wait no no wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait yeah
because
something was coming from admin no it
wasn't pewdiepie pie
it was pizza it's a dip it was foods and
weapons
[Applause]
uh that i'm sorry if the that wasn't you
i can't
i just just you at that's it all right
stick with charlie i don't think it's
him
this is in the middle oh god it wasn't
bobby
there's two killers i think we know who
we have to vote right i mean summit's
the one alive and he was being accused a
lot man yeah
yeah but that's exactly what they want
you to think add up getting voted off
and then
immediately trying to get me in the in
the mix dude that's exactly what they
want you to think we're gonna throw
because of it dude
um i had to wait one other thing uh
charlie why
why did you leave the seismic there's a
reason these tasks are going up so
fast bro i'm tasking my ass off charlie
wasn't with me he went towards
it then i went back when lyra came out
of electrical i went in because i
thought there might have been a kill
there wasn't oh okay so you were just
leaving it knowing i was gonna touch it
yeah yeah i'm thinking dk fine in the
body and dk fighting me randomly that
one time is making him
hella sucks what because you've had the
code client the whole time and you have
dakotas was in security for a lot of the
game i was next to him and then
near the end he was yeah but who feels
the most comfortable sitting in security
dude the killer someone does with those
guys
no no me and charlie were both in
security yeah
i finished my own my task it's got it's
got to be summoned here then all of us i
think it's something
else i think we know what to do sounds
good that sounds
[Applause]
[Music]
is my mic picking sorry i guess no
you're good okay
let's see if bobby does this task
all right i can't accuse bobby oh my god
oh that looks suspect wait who the [ __ ]
did i see fast kills man
okay where yes sir that was right below
the ship
actually oh no okay well it could have
been lyric i choose your charlie and my
yup yeah i fixed life just as one kill
it could have been lyric
xqc or charlie or me couldn't oh
okay okay okay okay you saw me come from
north i was in lab charlie should have
seen me yeah yeah
you were above you were above yeah yeah
uh listen
train
the only people who did the jobs in the
beginning everyone else was standing
around i went south to do the freaking
bridge thing where you hold the button
down or up okay i was holding it up and
it was 312. i just understand how you
can kill my man bobby like that
train where'd you go i fixed lights
instantly i project okay
which always pewdiepie
and charlie
you know what dakotas what was your
first task to cortez
i did uh i did the rockets yeah and it
does look suspect that i went from med
to to
left and i found the body but you know
it did look like you walked over him
where was there i don't think you're
saying wait where is pewdiepie if you
can vouch for him how can you vouch for
him because we walked
in on the body at the same time yeah it
looked like he was afk
but i don't know that he actually did it
that's my only success
uh it's kind of fun actually playing
with the people i don't know because i
don't know i'm not going for that stack
i don't know play patterns and i don't i
don't know anything so it's really like
i don't have no idea this is not a great
time to murder someone unless it's a
double
uh guys i have a first series of
questions can i say can i start first
hey uh mr pewdiepie you started the map
of pretty pretty hot what'd you do with
the first two things you did
uh i just did one thing what was it wait
are you accusing me out of nowhere
literally we could have talked about
this last round and the code has already
vouched for me as well
he's not the imposter it's just a
question what'd you do first
uh the [ __ ] thing at the top i don't
remember the meteor
no no no no no in office would you in
office when they around started
right now bro i don't even remember
being in office
okay okay yeah the download it's the
download on the right yeah
this gamer comment i think is wires not
download is it or there was a download
there
trend is download common to ask it's
wires
no no i'm asking is download a comment
as account i don't think so i did
downloads that's all i got
here's my question
yes
[Music]
you see where were you guys
okay yes i guess i have to remember
everything i
can do okay that person just died
they haven't just died immediately um
where's the body where's the body
it's telescope room same place as last
okay so i'll explain i'll explain it i'm
on
i'm currently on vitals and it's said
that um yellow was dead only
and by the time i got the left door uh
trent is dead and it's reported
upper which that that's almost he died
about two seconds ago
so where's everybody now i'm on security
cams right
i can attest to that uh charlie is on
cams that's actually true
uh lyric at the comms
and we were on the left side yeah i did
see you near the end but i don't know
where you came from though so
we were on the opposite side of the map
dude i don't know if you booked me
there was a murder on the other end of
them
most suspicious person from the last
time is pewds
someone vouched for me i didn't lie
about my task have anyone checked
there was a download yeah i bet so uh
lyric
it's hella says that you assess me same
with you xbc dude i suss
everybody i don't trust anyone everyone
says i don't know what the heck
i i couldn't kill you so easily there
larry
look look okay if pewdiepie is right
then sure i did see
most insecurity so then if it's not us
three it's xqc
or summit not stop it that makes sense
to me that actually makes a lot of sense
okay yeah because you're the only ones
near the body
either you see yourself guys guys
pewdiepie did not do it
[Music]
homies
yeah someone has to either see who
killed or it's him
all right i'm sticking with charlie
again this has to work actually
actually let's go here oh god i thought
i'd uh i thought i died jesus [ __ ]
crying
these imposters do not waste a second
and bobby were kicking it in cafeteria
relaxing whenever oh yeah so i trust him
i was not chilling but yeah we were
there
uh train and i went into admin i failed
card three times i left and found tran's
body in the dark yeah i was gonna call
you out for faking your test but you
didn't um
okay okay so listen so whenever whenever
you did your uh your
uh your failure i was scared of you
because i thought you'd fake the task no
i literally failed three times i failed
three times
yeah i i'll i'll believe it but i ran i
ran up that's why i didn't go to lights
there because i was scared of you
you killing me i'm voting bob because i
want him um
i was around three other people who saw
me just because
it was it was summit charlie and i don't
know why it's funny trolling in okay
which only leaves lyric and a depth i
was on the right i did see a depth and
then i lost her but i did uh the leaves
and i was i was running through lights
at the top well you can test me for all
you want but
i told you i i was scared she felt a
desk
i don't know why uh last time i was so
good at not dying i thought i figured
out the game finally
jesus christ it's bobby okay no it's not
you know he's dead
brown pink blue okay okay okay i will
say get ready
i i'm telling you guys right now both
the killers are purple and brown
okay but now i have to convince you guys
with arguments that it's both of them
i agree it's brown summit is back
lurking the entire game intelligible
looking for easy kills while we're
defending bobby doing tasks
real quick i was continuously going back
into election
do we have to fix the lights here this
is where i die
yeah this is where i die isn't not the
[ __ ] it
again there all right it cannot have
been adept or
charlie wouldn't have been any of us we
came across
you guys are going to listen to me where
did you go you guys are going to listen
to me very carefully okay
me and gb were again together the entire
round
okay we're together and we finally meet
a depth in storage that was locked
and then we meet a pewdiepie and charlie
so they're three stacked right
and i go up and you guys go with gp when
she goes down the lights go down there
and i run across the map so i can keep
my information safe
right and now what the [ __ ] are you
talking about
you know what i probably vented in and
killed her yeah that would have been
easy
it's easy where's everyone okay guys
guys if you're a formative game
please get your head on your shoulders
it's just the depth
and with the scouts this kill could not
have been heard
the whole time she was literally we were
literally stacked on
each other charlie listen
[Music]
oh god what is happening
are you serious at that
impressive oh my god
round one two and three and we never but
the whole point of the imposters is to
make sure that doesn't happen brother
i feel like i did such a bad job the
other time like i wasn't even serious
all right there's a there's a body
bottom right 100 i'm telling you 100
uh i think it's enough actually there's
a blip in that right now
i don't want to hear it
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah please be quiet okay okay
i see you um walk towards um
admin table from down the only place
that's down from there
lyrics only walk in i did i did
i did i did okay but the doors were
locked
i know the top door was locked i would
the bottom was not locked up okay okay
okay okay if you're on admin like you
said you were give me more information
wait bobby who did you vote on i saw a
cafeteria
i'm near admin i'm doing wires wait who
said that i don't know the names i saw
pink and
uh light science election electrical
i cleared myself a hundred times and i
saw three votes
oh well i cleared myself because i
scanned and i saw it so i'm cleared guys
i have so many things to do i hate this
map cause like
you bump into someone you're dead i
should have stayed with the group there
all right i'm just going to stay alive
oh bobby no
don't do me like this uh gb and bobby it
could be safe
or oh god all right all right
all right pewdiepie is running away from
lights it's right on top of lights
no i was not running anywhere baby yes
you were
you i just know you just earned yourself
another vote
yeah thank you bob he was feeling
because yeah yeah we were near each
other running
we were chilling yeah okay guys all your
son's
[Music]
you see bobby and i were in admin okay
guys guys
guys i have information i haven't
stopped voting pewdiepie stop well we
were in admin like
he bought me second gb was there too
then i went i went down into storage i
finished my
you you already [ __ ] up you're done
you're done
past me you're not gonna see a dev go
down anywhere i didn't see her at all
yeah yeah bobby stop by no i saw you
i saw you and admin being real suss and
then somebody else oh yeah
i was like tell him bobby yeah excuse me
stop voting please guys guys guys
when i when i called out the debt punch
okay i barely voted for myself okay
bobby rarely votes now he votes for
depth and now he jumps on the pewdiepie
training defense pewdiepie even even
though there's no no
bobby would never lie literally bobby
would never lie and bobby
i had already voted actually who did you
go actually who did you vote
appreciate pewdiepie i don't think it's
true
oh that's hilarious bobby's word means
nothing
i understand now there's five imposters
ah i thought i saw it i started
oh it was trained and trained get him
out
called it dog train 100 train i saw the
chop man
okay okay buddy i i need to level that
with you so you understand what
where what i'm gonna say okay so busy
right there we're all five stacked and
two of them are not
this is like uh we're all like students
and
xqc is like the sub the weird substitute
teacher
yeah i'm voting xqc
[Music]
dude now me and peter are actually gonna
do a mixtape together
why did you not vouch for me i was i was
next to you as well
no i was with you dude or
yeah all right i'm not killing bobby
not happening all right double kill
damn literally lyric
what up man administration oh charlie no
we'll be your
your downfall okay did he vent in there
nah he just he just um
i was on an admin and whenever uh lights
went down there's a camera on who's on
campus it's probably trying right now
no it's not me okay i dance under the
camera so i wouldn't die and then lyric
comes last
and i go up and there's a body it's just
lyric the lights went on and i started
moving towards
lights no no it's not a good test i saw
him a second to last last is lyric
yeah yeah last desert second to last i
mean but the lights are off lyric could
have very well pass the body no
no no way no no i did i didn't see
anybody i came from the
top right did the shoot came down to
admin i saw you go
left x you see and then you okay well
how did you see him go left were the
lights on because we were in admin
point i'm pretty sure the lights were on
at that point so actually go left i
wasn't expecting you to call me out
right there but if you saw the body and
cap
not stan why you think it's me i just
know you're saying that that's all i
know
i am innocent guys don't do this don't
do this it's too early
that's what a killer says oh my god
skipped
it safety safety all right yo bye
guys i will die please vote run out when
i die okay
we're just chilling with bobby he's
looking a little obsessed but i think
he's okay
he killed me already all right
uh all right we gotta sabotage it i
forgot how do i know if lights are off
[Music]
oh god hi that's the quotas
it's not gb what are you saying depends
on the body where's body
so i went uh i thought so gb followed
you up excuse me cafeteria before lights
went off i figured uh gb
killed you so i went to look for your
body and then i decided to go right i
see bobby at wires i go down dakota
comes up and adapts bodies at shields
so wait did you go did you see gb come
back down or she continue to go up
i saw gb and dakotas both come down and
they went to electrical so i went to
look for the body
because cafeteria doors were locked and
then i went right and dakota comes up
past me to nav and adapts bodies and
shields
what if lyric just killed and hid inside
of a vent no no no no no because i
electrical if i killed someone at
shields i can guarantee you i would have
vented and not
risked being seen i did all three of my
tasks in electrical and during that time
i saw gb ending that was my problem but
i here's my problem
um somebody who's somebody who killed
there uh used the fact that kem's are
off because you called coms
so somebody killed in the vicinity of a
camera because they call the comms
and then i think dakotas was running up
and that's what exactly the comms are
train i think that you're a third
imposter and i think if i would have
killed someone at shields i would have
vented
that's what i think i'm thinking i
passed adept she was alive when i passed
her yeah but then who was there you
should have seen someone there
i saw xqc i passed him near nav
no bobby was a nav no i think wait no
someone was at nav
sorry i seen someone yeah i went from
electrical through navigate uh
and then yeah make sure you if you
believe just go with what you believe
i'm skipping voting on it it's a free
shot at a oh yikes
uh lyric also skipped again i think it's
doesn't move
do not kill do not kill bobby
do not kill bobby i'm protecting him
you saw that right summit it was green
dakotas thank you
wait why i mean i was going no matter
what right
no matter what he did take some of him
dude
i trust the dakotas wow wait pewdiepie
when did dakotas come in
like dakotas was top like i ended up
running to top o2 from the bottom
i i am i don't see anything i was just
chilling with bobby honestly
dakota's right now i'm hella suss on you
wait judy why are you uh
when he came in train did that right in
front of you something and you're gonna
really believe that
when i got right neon bro i don't even
know which voice is which i don't know
if you're a crew mate you're vote
trained right now by myself was doing
bottom o2 admin trains come
train comes in dakotas comes in then we
all together
go to the top one because we're worried
that no one's doing it but it does get
done
so we're in cafeteria we all decided to
group up and go up there anyways to see
what the
you guys are doing and then the green
guy sliced the [ __ ] you know
she sees that summit train is right in
front of you and he did it bro
like right next how certain are you on
this man
i don't know who to vote for wait wait
wait we can solve this we can solve this
we can solve this
we can solve this guys i know how i know
how long please listen listen
bobby who do you think it is i think
it's train
all right bobby all right
i'm trusting yesterday train guys lyric
dude please tell me you voted in dk all
right please
i'm trusting you right here man you guys
swear thank you man congratulations
trust yum hella suss on bobby right now
he just jumped in the line of fire like
he was the president bro
no i thought it was i i i think it's
train bobby it's a [ __ ] chat
dude i don't know everyone's sticking
together
this makes it tough
lights went out i saw light blue go
right body was storage
i think it is it might be poods man i'm
literally just trying to stay alive
as soon as the lights go as i always go
away lyric name the last two tasks you
did
i i'll be honest i was not doing tasks
because
i was trying more to see what the hell
you guys are doing look
xuc said it was me the first round i am
innocent i
saw a blue [ __ ] no one right
i did not go right i literally didn't
even go there dying wish
sure but some people's dying wishes are
wrong
all right it's five and we know one's
out i said we vote lyric and then we
stay together for the game
look all right you can vote me out
that's fine just be cautious of light
blue okay this is excuses dying i will
be sacrificing
scared remember me i just want
me and bob in the end we're gonna we're
gonna do this me and bob we got this
it's all right so now we just gotta kill
anyone that's not chibi really
what so hasty pewdiepie it has to be
pewdiepie
holy [ __ ] it has to be him hopefully
someone will come through here
no it's train it's trade
bobby you gotta listen to me man listen
it wasn't lyric lyrics said it's
pewdiepie we should have left bobby
you've been with me the whole game
oh bobby please bobby yeah
no listen right now this round who went
right said me you and gb
correct pewdiepie was nowhere to be seen
pewdiepie comes from the left
kills uh gb and now he's blaming me
lyric blame them last what the [ __ ]
are you saying because because beauty
could have killed me a few times
if it was him that's not good enough
because he could be using you as an ally
what do you mean that's not good enough
what an alibi think about it think about
it okay
if i know you're new to the game i could
stick around you not kill you and then
when it gets dude he's talking down to
yourself [ __ ] hard
well i'm not talking down to you okay
what's your defense bobby
bobby you knew he would stream from last
okay let him defend his son
let me defend myself no cutie come on
now it's your turn go
well it's not me obviously i said
okay i said it i was with you the whole
time i could have killed you a million
times bobby
that's what i think i'm sorry and and
and you knew you voted
trained last round as well you knew it
was trained i was with you
literally right there right yes but then
i was like
you know no no you're trying to confuse
it
literally makes no sense bobby bobby
bobby you're my boy
yo let's make a diss track
[Laughter]
call it one train hell yeah bobby
i'm sorry i'm so sorry
[Music]
no matter what that was my only strat i
was not trying to trick you i just
wanted us in the end dude
no i'm mad right now oh yeah we all in
here trains me
wrong all right this might might be fun
bobby would not do me like that
i don't think bobby would fake around
two lights right all right bobby's safe
let's stay with bobby
oh great i was gonna do asteroids
just chilling with homie no
no
train for that no way i was on
logs bro you never passed the y corridor
bro cause i don't i don't fully trust
something i saw him but there yet the
body was there
i'm gonna feel so terrible if it's wrong
i remember first round lights went out
charlie went left that was weird okay
cool
guys listen why did you buy that train
because somebody just came out why do
you guys feel bad when you're voting
okay
who is he still learning jesus
without hearing their all right i have
emotion man it's an entire double-edged
sword the whole game
is the death gonna kill me i thought
she'd kill me all right well it's not
uh i think it i swear as before the
lights were going out i swear i saw
bobby man
it was bobby i was just running with
three people okay i want to ask
for first through hard clears just just
as a pointer who did the fuel
who knows they did the fuel you mean who
else did the fuel
come on guys what's the fuel sorry
you'll adapt
adapt where's the fuel
anybody fuel fuel
yeah i did it yeah okay then i think
this is correct there's stupid people
that did it because it has bar
i think these are all three good you
ever charlie oh wait i didn't do fuel
sorry
okay we've seen pewdiepie pass no so
this is what i was going to tell you i
actually saw a teal
that was going to happen as they wake up
so it couldn't have been
i like how into the game they are though
summit
faked his shields task oh what
what what the [ __ ] are you smoking okay
how can you possibly know where i was
if the lights go out while i'm on a
[ __ ] task
okay how do you know when i get off that
test
he sounds genuinely angry so it's hard
to tell unless shroud had a shroud-like
scooter accident and broke his arm okay
he faked his cast hundred percent
because it's probably tell me how
explain it then just don't
expect because the shield's gonna be
it'd be so funny if the other one is
bobby
i feel like it right this is not saying
it i run away from lights
i keep saying what are you smoking what
are you smoking whether i'm still on
that task or not huh brother yes
i'm done that's really going all the way
until it was at zero
guys you can still skip on seven uh out
of respect
but it's summit i have no respect but
i'm skipping anyway
[Music]
oh lyric no listen
it says there is a true body okay i left
summit and lyric up top
and there's two bodies now can we can we
please not vote before we lose again no
no no no man i
saw you i saw boots you see you guys
were on light and then i'm
running down and then you guys super
suss on x because i think so too
many
i thought it was bobby first round but
not anymore
i'm about to turn him on like 10 db he
said to lyric oh don't do that
okay 22nd each
you wanted me to talk oh man no bro
how emotional are you going to get in
this dude before you just tell them can
i talk to you
you know what i mean bobby i just i just
look at you at the door
you know the door that opens to the
that's you right you were there
yeah i was there okay i was at pewds um
there was lyric in summit i went down i
saw you because
admin says that that somebody was there
and i want to look it it was you i go
back
there's two bodies there is two of them
it's both summit and lyric i think we
will sum it up first
i think that i think we killed among us
with this game
you feel you felt that too right now
bobby if the game doesn't end here it
means that the vote was correct
otherwise we lose instantly what a way
to talk to him dude
i think i made that mistake two games
ago where i took the game two series
and then it's just like not fun i had so
much more fun when i
just generally no no i was about to
report bobby
and she hit the button before i could i
was going up to
electrical and she she killed the body
no
bobby you got this i was literally about
to report man
bro we can literally end the game right
now if you vote
she killed xqc on the top of the y
and just i was about to report but she's
self-reported come on bobby you got this
yeah we're gonna throw if you don't vote
right now
don't push bobby like why don't you put
that bro it is on you though man
lyric and summit wanted to kill xqc they
wanted to vote him off last round we
would have i didn't
trust summit or xqc
is making a good point at least yeah but
xcc was he was accusing me since the
first round
[Music]
he made the right decision this time
boys hell yeah
gg yeah that's some good [ __ ]
all right thanks for playing all the
best guys take care
uh i think it started off maybe a little
bit sweaty but i think
we had some really good games i had a
good time even if it ends now remember
this is good times because it's like
it's been really cool
go check out the other streamers go you
know go check out bobby
okay guys
[Music]
foreign